la culture et les insolites avec
Véronique pour commencer les insolites
de la semaine qui ont retenu votre
attention et on commence par une bonne
nouvelle pour les fans de Chouchou ceux
qui ont regardé aussi un gars une fille
voilà à qui je fais allusion je pense
que vous avez vous avez compris c'est
évidemment à Alexandra Lamy qu'on va
pouvoir voir en chair et en os moi j'ai
un petit côté people j'aime bien voir
les vedettes en vrai donc pour ça il
faut aller se pas compliqué à l'UGC par
l'idée au Chesnay dimanche 29 janvier à
15h parce qu'il y aura le film d'Eric
barbier qui s'appelle alors toujours
envie de dire tout il est beau c'est pas
du tout ça c'est zodi et tu pardon les
frères du désert c'est l'histoire de
dromadaire pour changer des brebis et
donc c'est une jolie histoire d'un petit
garçon qui est drief le l'acteur donc il
se représente Alexandra Lamy il y a
cédrief Eric Barbie réalisateur donc
c'est une histoire entre un petit garçon
et un dromadaire un dromadaire qui a des
grosses grosses qualités de coureurs
parce qu'il y a des gens très longues
vous êtes au courant bah j'ai déjà vu la
bande annonce mais
bon bref c'est un film tout public qui a
l'air très très chouette et je vous
encourage à y aller alors c'est
l'occasion de découvrir ce film de aussi
faire la rencontre de l'équipe du film
de poser des questions c'était toujours
agréable on continue avec une revue qui
vous a scotché ça s'appelle Les Carnets
de Versailles on va faire un 3 en 1
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire ce que
c'est que ce qu'est cette revue je vais
y arriver commence la Procure et ce
qu'elle contient alors bah beaucoup de
choses donc ça s'appelle Les Carnets de
Versailles alors là j'ai l'impression de
de d'avoir découvert quelque chose mais
en fait non ça existe depuis assez
longtemps au numéro 21 c'est un magazine
semestriel voilà qui est édité par le
château de Versailles et vous avez à la
fois l'intérieur des des articles de
fonds en général en rapport avec
l'actualité donc là on a l'exposition
Louis XV enfin il y a plein de choses
vous avez des photos des programmations
l'agenda et ce qui est génial c'est que
c'est complètement gratuit donc en fait
vous pouvez vous sur le site les carnets
de versailles.fr vous avez un coupon
d'abonnement à remplir et vous recevrez
gratuitement tous les semestres votre
votre magazine pas du tout je
connaissais pas du tout et du coup on le
dit c'est pas distribué
gratuitement c'est Lucie Nicola William
qui m'a dit tout ça c'est la rédacteur
en chef du journal alors à l'intérieur
comme je vous ai dit c'est très riche
vous avez par exemple là en rapport avec
l'exposition Louis XV ce qui se termine
le 19 février entre parenthèses des
péchons-nous pour ceux qui l'ont pas vu
vous avez par exemple Julia cristella à
qui on a la psychanalyste à qui on a
devant demander de psychanalyser c'est
du radiaire Louis XV donc sur le divan
elle s'est aidé d'un portrait de du duc
de Luynes alors le 15 n'était ni vif et
plutôt atrabilaire un peu obsédé par la
mort et bon ben voilà c'est comme ça et
puis il y a aussi autre chose que j'ai
découvert c'est
des photos magnifiques qui ont été
faites par Jérémy Villet qui est un donc
je passe à mon troisième sujet Jérémy
Villet oui on peut découvrir ces photos
on m'a écrit les rôles entre la Pointe
tout à fait honnête avec des
téléspectateurs
[Musique]
c'est pas grave Véronique c'est les
insolites de Véronique à chaque fois sur
TV 70 il a été hébergé dans la maison du
jardinier près du Grand Trianon pour
pouvoir commencer dès l'aube et terminer
son travail dans la nuit exactement
merci alors du coup c'est un jeune
yvelino imaginez-vous qui a grandi dans
une ferme dans les Yvelines et c'est là
où il a acquéri ce goût de la nature la
vie sauvage et il y a 10 ans maintenant
il est il s'est destiné à la profession
enfin sa passion photographe animalier
voilà en 2019 il a sorti un livre qui
s'appelle première neige donc lui son sa
spécialité c'est plutôt les étendues
nageuses le Grand Nord etc mais là les
carnets de Versailles lui ont demandé de
prendre possession des lieux donc du
parc une fois le public parti et
d'ailleurs il raconte que bah dès que le
public est parti les animaux sortent et
il a des photos sont dans ce carnet et
sont aussi sur le site les carnets de
Versailles il importe il faut lui vous
pouvez voir toutes les photos qu'il a
prises magnifiques alors évidemment il y
a un écosystème incroyable c'est des
serres des renards des lièvres tout un
tas d'oiseaux et ce qui est génial c'est
que c'est un décor quand même
particulier entre le château les statues
et il y a une espèce de corrélation et
notamment une photo d'un oiseau qui est
la statue de cheval on a l'impression
que le cheval le regarde vraiment ça
rend vivant les statuts et ça leur donne
un mouvement quel nom évidemment pas
voilà et si on veut en savoir plus sur
lui on peut regarder le sur le site de
France 2 il y a les paradis blanc c'est
paradis blanc qui ont été diffusés mais
ça ment par Laurent Delahousse tout à
fait dans son magazine 13h15 ce dimanche
il se trouve que vous avez quatre
épisodes de 20 minutes qui sont c'est
donc un documentaire sur Jérémy Viller
qui a été suivi de la Norvège jusque
dans les Yvelines sa fameuse ferme où il
a vécu et là on voit des rencontres
insolite incroyable alors avec quelques
humains mais surtout beaucoup d'animaux
sauvages dont notamment un loup et
franchement c'est ces photos sont pas
belles mais juste sublime Facebook
plaisir et allez voir bon ben merci
Véronique pour une prochaine pour nous
en faire partager d'autres merci Grégory
merci